did you hear the half let's not draw
from the Batman great Greg where you
going Greg Greg Greg hello reject no my
dear what are going to watch the honest
gorilla or Shrek this is Greg not what
doesn't need an RN right this is ha ha
ha I need a star over here
from the channel and need a star channel
need a star channel why not that were
your show no but I my name is Anita star
fans have been voting for what they want
they're honest Rhoda to be the number
one boat is Shrek the number one votes
Shrek the number one building I was on
screen junkies news last week and nice
ignore it like one of the main head
runners of I think you'd like to head
runner of stream junkie fan he thanked
me for doing prior reactions and he
encourages me to do reaction reach other
so I have permission he can't get on my
a pathetic junkie but greater than make
Shrek into it and on a turn on it is
really really exciting and appreciate
you what we junkies cut you aboard our
awesome and we're making the honest
trailers that you voted for here's the
honest trailer you voted number one for
some reason
haha my car so on in the studio that
well to the dream workspace comes the
animated feature that Ritter is a little
difficult better out than in I always
say by adding 90 minutes of know
something Joe Hart live and over no I
don't look like we're slowly about
upward stupid stinky smelly ugly alders
actually resisted where he transport it
was over who sounds just like that one
voice Mike Meyers
faster I got that I could choke up don't
care when is a gas based way of life is
threatened just set off on a quest with
donkey a character is sadly more famous
than Eddie Murphy VB ha ha ha princess
brother has by over disorder and an
entire kingdoms worth of fairy tale
characters that Disney had yet to snatch
up together the food that nothing can
overcome the power of true love
or more specifically the power of having
a dragon murder your enemy Wow
really just straight up killed him at
the end wait so who's running the
government now you just started the coup
why are you dancing this walk that's
early computer energy ridges that looks
just as good as modern computer ha ha ha
ha and it's rendering for a story that
carries all the overused disney trucks
full of overused is neat rows why the
reluctant ugly hero who thinks no one
can love them but no nonsense princess
the creepy horny government official who
wants to be king and a lovable animal
sidekick hey you can't beat them join
them
well it's the same time mercilessly
mocking them settle in for a story with
an important lesson only ugly people can
be together
wait that can't be your own kinda yo
sure people deserve ridicule men of
farquaad's stature are in short supply
oh hey look you guys are doing the
Macarena ah references so come along for
the blockbuster hit then appeal to
adults and kids alike and when the first
Academy Award for Best Animated please
really well by making fun of is nice
obsession with franchising and
merchandise hottest boy one great sequel
oh yeah let's spit off Broadway musicals
a ton unfortunate Green merchandise and
that Smash Mouth song that's been stuck
in your head since 2001
oh my god sorry Chris Bartlett's every
Hills Club ah many me mother a donkey
man creepy animation error is the time
of delivery for small C what's up little
they read names of amusing them
no sure oh no try to see me no no no no
no trick is not real trick is not like
oh we like this drag be sure to
subscribe for more honest trailers
thanks to fans more es Connor I and Rene
G for helping to vote Shrek the number
one fan choice honest trailer and thanks
to epic Lloyd of epic rap battles for
its epic Smash Mouth vocal alright I
thought it yeah it helps make Fan
Appreciation Month great to check out
all of our fans voted honest trailers
including our epic collaboration with
Michael Baldwin on Willy Wonka and the
Chocolate Factory
click the Box on the left and if you
can't get enough kids movies put the Box
in the right to see which ones are
actually worth watching
hey now you're all Allstars this is my
swamp not the buttons not the gumdrop
buttons according to all known laws of
aviation wait wrong movie ogres are like
onions it's all over now
shrek is love no I like it why sure get
lost shrek is life is one of the
weirdest really see I wanted to watch
that but I was like I don't want to
watch it because I felt like I may have
wanted to do a reaction to that now you
should feel not brave enough to bring
what is weird and creepy yeah what can I
recommend to watch because doing them
all they are all very disturbing they
all right on my own okay right okay
Godric you know it's been a long time
since I've seen Shrek
I always thought twice when it first
came in the haters I loved it weirdly I
felt like I got the jokes even more as I
got older yeah well yeah there's a lot
of adult there's a lot of young humor
there it's some kind of like dirty humor
and they're hurting videos right at my
Ally's right up your alley dirty alley
of yours is dirtier but I like the
references that they made with the
Disney entities characters and such like
yeah I mean it's true they always have
like that ugly and secure guy and then
they have that lovable pet care and they
have a badass princess you know I'm like
Shrek and you're like Fiona I'm like yes
what an ogre form hey that's that is the
only form I think as the only form you
should be you forever
yeah the only way I find you most
attractive that's the loader that that
is the way I am oh my skinny white girl
form nah that's just not it's so
overdone who even wants that it's not
it's not even explained that people are
into no one's at you legs perhaps the
skinny white girl days anyway girls all
about part of the spectrum fat look far
from fat I'm okay with it I would you're
not Michael skinny like a twig my name
is the skinny one day I will be I mean I
like skinny like thin yeah you know me
we have a very nice to hear you I would
love that work men get in my belly
oh good motto a bastard references
everywhere that's true all over the Mike
my
do the same boy yeah that bastard and
movie how did a was married an axe
murderers yeah he's really good at that
boys yeah his thing
well isn't his family like in their
their British though Oh like his family
I thought he was left from Scottish
descent my bad I mean British is hunama
Scottish is British technically really
yeah
Great Britain is not just like British
doesn't just meaning Chinese Japanese Oh
plan yeah
socket their own grief racist jokes
that's what you get from ogres while
mirroring a lot of these Disney films
and these tropes and appreciating that
also did a great job at scooping the
movie great Zubin stress too was amazing
as well the last couple films they like
I watch some dandelion OTT watch them
they were horrible third one was really
bad and then the fourth one was just
like I don't even remember it I just
remember not liking it at all did you
see Puss in Boots uh yeah it's alright
yeah it was all right as i do i yeah
all right so cute I didn't know Shrek
was the first movie to win an Oscar for
with that for real were they serious
no the other being serious crazy I think
that I think it's very interesting that
this was the number one quest rightly
like really that's crazy to make this
song be in Hairy Maclary this back to
that also is called also it's good as
long do we do become super famous
because hey man this is legendary I
think people are gonna down such a way
to get download this new version they
have here probably I'll be amazing to
download that I memorize those that was
cool like the way they have changed yeah
cuz it all fit the right syllable
formation and everything that was
written very letter or it's like they
have a whole set up a few more regular
yeah yeah well listen you charity you
we're having we're having in total you
know today now I'm talking to you I'm
talking to them I taught me to see we
are balloon did weaker
I'm carrying a conversation why would we
do that when we can just talk to you I
just want to get a word then well guys
subscribe to screen junkies scribe to
the junkies I'm a huge screen junkies
fan I've been actually Gretchen I'm
gonna be on movie vs. movie Jon flicks
picks one Flickinger because they that
again Vic he has a new show on screen
junkies I'm going on one of the episodes
movie versus movie I was on screen
junkies News philosophy I want to go
back on movie fight yeah I was on movie
fights like Thank You shun year and a
half ago I didn't quite get the full
concept of movie fight so I didn't do
that great of a job but I've watched
like probably a hundred movie five
episodes even ready I'm ready I want to
go back and it's ready if you're
watching bring me back subscribe to the
real reject subscribe ready to hear me
alright
we like clapping critics out there I do
a star subscribe to the real reject you
can look at my channels but you know
probably well shout out the nipples
nipples whose nipple nipple just in
general this one this who has richest
like totally got the nebula oh and you
can touch it no come on
come on just get a little tech flick it
like the flick big ah lobby